how are your doctors going
awful
what
travis and i want to have a baby and so
my doctor
took us down this road of doing ivf and
like it hasn't been
the most amazing experience the
medication that they've been giving me
they put me into menopause kourtney
kardashian reveals that her ivf
medication put her into early menopause
literally into menopause the 42 year old
pooch founder opens up about trying to
have a baby with travis barker on the
family's new hulu series the kardashians
admitting it hasn't exactly been smooth
sailing i think because i'm so clean and
careful with what i put into my body
it's just like having the complete
opposite reaction and is working as a
contraceptive instead of helping us
the medication basically like put me
into depression i've never seen you
happier
so the depression thing surprised me and
i have everything in the world to be
happy about i just feel super moody and
hormonal like i'm a lunatic half the
time and all that echoes what the
reality star told et earlier this month
what has it been like to be on the path
to baby with travis i mean it's a
beautiful thing that we'd love to have
happen um but
you know the journey is a bit hard for
any women who have been on it and
emotional
yeah of course court shares three
children with her ex scott disick
twelve-year-old mason nine-year-old
penelope and seven-year-old reign while
travis has two kids with his ex shayna
moekler 18 year old landon and 16 year
old alabama my children are my first
priority and you know that's one thing
that you know travis and i you know do
agree on our children come first and
their happiness and as long as you know
the kardashians are good to my kids you
know that's all that matters to me as a
mom
even though courtney has
three beautiful children it doesn't make
it
hurt any less
if you're trying to have a baby and
you've been struggling we want it so
badly because we want to make something
together you want to bring your own like
our baby your own love into the world in
the way you know that you know
exactly how you both know how it feels
to have a child and how to bring a child
into the world and now you want to do it
with the love of your life last month a
source told et that the idea of having a
child is very important and exciting to
the couple adding that their family is
very supportive of the idea oh we all
love it this is her time to shine baby
court and the blank 182 drummer got
engaged back in october and thanks to
the family's new series fans are getting
an inside look at the days leading up to
the big proposal i told your mom i've
been like
madly in love with courtney forever
and i believe she's my soul mate
and oh my god i'm gonna cry
to her
on the day that i met her for the day
that i first was with her
oh my god i'm literally crying i'm
crying all over again
oh my god i'm so happy for you guys
and while we'll just have to wait until
next week to see how it all goes down we
do know court says yes in fact the two
said i do in an unofficial las vegas
ceremony earlier this month you did a
practice run on the wedding
congratulations thank you
so when is the real wedding we don't
know yet we're just you know living our
best lives
[Music]
you